The Joe Rogan Experience it's very weird
that we spent more on this than Russia
spent doing The Invasion we now
surpassed what Russia has spent but what
about this FTX thing oh yeah well that's
where it gets crazy which I love is
they're all reporting on like how could
this happen like you know he would play
League of Legends while he's on the
phone doing a 20 million dollar deal and
then who was it Goldman Sachs somebody's
like I love this kit they all think it's
great how could they think that's great
because he's a rich kid with connected
parents it's not if he's just some jerk
off off this tree to look like that
right they wouldn't be like oh this is
great well his mom was a big uh
Democratic party uh operative right
wasn't she something yeah also MIT the
guy at the SEC that he would talk to was
an MIT Professor go back Jamie would you
just show me I was trying to find the
actual thing and that wasn't it but this
is what he was talking about crypto's
biggest crash saw a guy playing League
of Legends while luring investors so
while he's looking for he was playing
this [ __ ] game while he was talking
to the the investors if you just pay a
bunch of money to the media just which
what he did
they'll just write things about how
great you are that's the other thing he
was a jerk off yeah they'll write your
because there's only two kinds of
stories my friend I used to work with
she told me it's either puff uh uh
outrage it's like puff pieces or hip
pieces that's all they do because that's
with that's how you get people to look
at it and whatever so you can bribe
these companies to do puff pieces that's
what he did isn't that wild the guy from
uh Shark Tank that they asked him he's
like I'd work with him again I think he
was actually one of the guys that got
paid too of course I think he's one of
the spokespeople wasn't he yeah Kevin
O'Leary yeah he had to get some fun
disclosures on that video or he was like
before we get started on this let me
tell you that all my business accounts
are involved in FTX and I've invested
dude there's a video of him goodness on
Shark Tank tearing apart some guy who
brought a Ponzi scheme to him oh No in
fact when I say I think it's coffee
Zillow maybe he believes in this kid
yeah I bet he does it's just if you know
the right people and you're that his
brother works with like a gap or
something a guard against pandemics
every single thing that you would see
did you see what the young lady said she
posted it on Twitter about her regular
amphetamine use oh they're checking
people see make life what does she say
makes real life seem silly uh yeah see
if we can find out what her post was but
she was talking on Twitter about how uh
consuming amphetamines on a regular
basis yeah here it is made non-medicated
life seem dumb oh no [ __ ]
it was the BC the obvious the obvious
things they're saying what a [ __ ]
look nothing like regular amphetamine
used to make you appreciate how dumb a
lot of normal non-medicated human
experiences that is a hilarious thing to
say from someone who had in April 5th of
2021 is responsible for how much money
dude but you know it's crazy they're all
whacked out on on legal prescription
drugs yeah yeah they're whacked out
there's another thing that he was taking
in a transdermal patch he was taking a
sledge lean or something like that I
just watched that dude he's like two
more dates yeah and more police more
dates Derek that guy knows all this oh
my God was he like a chemical engineer
he's just [ __ ] super smart and reads
research I know it's so funny people I
thought he was a chemist
everybody ever knew that was some kind
of Fitness freak knew a lot of [ __ ]
about they weren't like stupid people
that shouldn't do research they were way
ahead of everyone else I knew because
you know how like uh
weightlifting supplements oh yeah man
like I know a lot of people that know a
lot of [ __ ] about like when you should
eat for the maximum amount of absorption
the protein yeah right how many grams
per pound of body weight you have to
take that kid with that fledgling that's
amazing I kid that out of shape is like
weight lifter knowledge of nootropics
that's his body his body is his mind his
body's just carrying his mind around
with the effects he said it does where
it makes you uh like enjoy doing like
boring work or something I think yeah I
think it was something along those lines
well so find find Derek's video on it
because Derek describes it but the
sledgling one he had like a nicotine
patch was like a patch yeah so just like
getting that slow drip of whatever the
[ __ ] that's crazy that stuff stays in
you for a while those kind of things
those ones where it stays for a while
you can't just go off it it's
transdermal yeah
I don't know it's a 20 minute video This
is the part would be maybe
just started yeah right there that's the
stuff that's the stuff yeah I'm Sam like
this
okay so he's gonna go he has his medical
disclaimer he's smart about the way he
handles stuff so guys Derek more played
tomorrow dates.com today we're talking
about Sam bankman freed and his
nootropic use his drug use his cognitive
enhancing dopaminergic enhancing drugs
that he's using to stay uh cognitively
cognitively [ __ ] dial dude
um for being the hyper productive
entrepreneur that is bro if you haven't
seen him because you've probably seen if
you're clicking this the FTX debacle
he's all in the news
um and has been for a minute now crypto
fears contagion as billions owed to
creditors Sam bakeman Freud becomes an
ESG truth teller FDX fires three of Sam
bankman for its top deputies celebs like
Tom Brady Larry David did ads for crypto
giant FTX now they're getting sued Sam
bankman freeze says [ __ ] Regulators
musk's Twitter ultimatum and making tick
tocks instead of ads this is Matt Levine
on the collapse of sand bankman fridge
FDX and Alameda so apparently this guy
went from a billionaire to nothing
essentially over 9 right from this
complete disaster of a situation if you
want some insight onto exactly what
happened check out coffeezilla high
quality information on a regular basis
in a highly entertaining format highly
recommend this channel for anything
crypto scam related essentially or
anything Financial you know who has a
good thing on FTX that is not make any
conclusions to uh this guy upper echelon
games I watch a really good it's
actually like great I can't remember
what if it's about FTX when it fell and
he doesn't claim anything he just shows
like it's it's worth watching that other
guy uh the guy who is the head dog at
Google was it Google or Facebook chemov
where was he from is it from Google
right
at the Venture Capital fund I don't know
he probably used to work there wasn't he
like the top guy of Google anyway he's a
billionaire and he really understands it
and he actually reached out to them
contacted them and said you know you
should form a board and they told him to
go [ __ ] himself that's literally what
they said I love this kid he was like
he's a [ __ ] billionaire Financial guy
who actually understands how money works
and he said look this is what you guys
got to do and they're like go [ __ ]
yourself do you think the nootropics
were making them arrogant but they're on
speed all day man these guys are jacked
up on speed and they're all [ __ ]
billions and they're [ __ ] each other
all of them there's all nine of them and
a house in the Bahamas just smells like
nerd [ __ ] just nerd [ __ ]
just taking Mountain Dew and sledgling
using a trackball these tweets on the
side of this are crazy that's probably
what he's talking about was he saying uh
it says like M Sam has fatal side
effects when eating with meat products
yeah oh so is that why he's a vegan it's
that fearlessness pathological gambling
and hypersexuality have you heard of
this before another I've heard
I've heard I just realized the Ultimate
gift basket for his lips is the one FTX
did which is a [ __ ] ton of money yeah oh
that's better than the yeah the fake
money than a designer T-shirt If that if
that guy didn't go to war with that
other guy that's what happened right
that dude dumped all of his coins he he
he sold all his coins I really couldn't
cover it yeah yeah that was his like
rival
yeah they had he had a whole back door
installed in that so that his kind of
house one of girlfriend or whatever she
is ran Alameda research right and then
they had something they funneled off
like 10 billion dollars into that it's
the whole thing is so wild they were
just on Speed playing with fake money
it's so it's so funny to watch the
videos where it's obvious and all you
need is people to be on board yeah if
all the right people are on board that's
all it takes it's like the Epstein
Island thing yeah everyone it's like
everything's to train you to get to be
uh like you don't really get to pay if
you say whatever your politics right
right whatever you would call yourself
you don't get to decide that like we'll
let you know what you are right you
could decide maybe a gender you go ahead
and pick out a gender honey but you're
not getting to pick everything else
about your identity will be assigned to
you from now on you can only even that
can only be assigned if it's convenient
you see what happened with the
non-binary shooter oh yeah the
transgender person on television says I
could tell by looking at them that
that's a man
well what are you what do they do in
that situation where they have we played
it on Jimmy show that is such a crazy
thing to say like that is against
everything you supposedly stand for did
you see initially so it's Al Franken
some other white guy the the reporter
the woman and then I can't remember the
black guy's name but she she's like
first here in the non-binary thing so
now they're in a bad spot right because
you're supposed to like immediately go
along with that right you know air
resistant and she and this is like
really screwing up their Narrative of
whatever they were gonna say uh the the
uh this person uh was right and so they
had to turn the black guy because
they're like I hope
because we're white like we can't say
anything like I hope this is enough of a
shield for us to say we don't want to
accept that the shooter is non-binary
and then they had to get a trans woman
to come and go he doesn't look
non-binary to me I'm just so crazy to
say that the whole rule is set up that
way in fact I first heard about on from
uh that guy Adam Curry on here ESG a
long time ago yes
and I was like oh is that what that is I
was wondering where all this bizarre it
sounds like it's a tax write-off it's so
like what like are they they must be
making money in some way or getting a
grant to do this yeah that's what it is
that's exactly what it is yeah
it's wild
they're profiting off of a mind virus
you could Juke the numbers however you
want if you pay you pay into it I think
like a carbon like your personal carbon
and it sounds good you're trying to make
the world a better place a more
Equitable Place beautiful place more
diverse place he said that openly and
also that it was [ __ ] openly to
someone he thought was giving him a
favorable article
because they're all really really uh kid
gloves with this FTX kid he must have
paid out it is weird how their kid
gloves with them right like some some
places not at all in other places like
trying to paint him as a person who just
made mistakes yeah the whole point of
giving somebody a [ __ ] ton of money is
not so you have to give them orders of
what to they just have an inside like no
he's one of the good ones I know like we
hate billionaires here but this guy gave
us like
Millions yeah he duked out doesn't Bill
Gates do that too doesn't he donate like
millions and millions of dollars to
these movies because he used to be not
he used to be a hated guy well he still
is by some but I mean in the media I
remember that when he was like a bad guy
you know when they had the Anti-Trust
right and uh and now they can't say
enough and then you find all these
things like common I don't have kids so
I I Remember Common Core came out and I
would just hear everybody complaining
about common core
that's his the bill of Melinda Gates
Foundation right money made that a
national thing I didn't know about that
at the time like a ton yeah
speaking at a New York Times event yeah
two days yeah oh and he'll be there he
says which is crazy do they arrest him
on the spot I don't think so
that's wild what happens there I don't
know wait oh go down a little see wait
go down a little bit yeah Larry Fink so
that's the guy I think he's the guy that
invented ESG right that's his thing
isn't it um
CEO of BlackRock
so there's all these business folks
there's another Benjamin Netanyahu
there's people in the Bahamas looking
for him right now from like the crypto
Community wow
it's a real Epstein island of notable
people coming oh you gotta imagine
there's probably some bad people that
lost Millions Bill billions yeah I don't
know how much people I mean I mean a lot
of people did but I mean some of them
are bad people you know what I'm saying
oh yeah yeah can you imagine all these
people know like van Jones especially
you know that guy knows the deal because
they got him on camera what's his name
filmed them they're like you know this
is all [ __ ] you're talking about
Russia Gates remember yes I'm freaking
the guy's name Buddy Veritas yeah James
O'Keefe so that's him I mean it's not
cut anyway van Jones is saying it I know
a bunch of people from especially being
in New York and all the comics would do
uh cable news stuff you know like red
eye we do and you meet these people and
they're all like
they all know the game and assume you do
too and then if I meet people that think
it's all like they just can't imagine
something nefarious was
oh yeah of course zelenski's there he's
not busy boy that guy on he's getting
around